ex
[Musique]
c'est une scène des plus banales dans
une grande partie du monde mais ici
cette jeune femme à vélo cheveux au vent
est une sorte de rebelles elle défie les
règles de transformation
amina et saoudienne d'origine mais elle
vit en egypte depuis près de 10 ans mais
ni de coeur de prouver qu il en
demi-finale every thing co2 many people
commente was there are they share des
commandes du paradis à la fête sur
l'adolescence elle a pris conscience que
tout ce qu'elle faisait
c'était pour plaire aux autres en
particulier à sa famille elle a choisi
une autre voie
amina avait fait des études en sciences
elle a opté pour la décoration
intérieure
[Musique]
et elle a décidé de ne plus porter le
hidjab
à 25 ans elle réalise aujourd'hui que
son choix de changer de vie avait
quelque chose à voir avec le printemps
arabe et les événements historiques de
la place tahrir au caire est ce qu'un
jour notre hymne pointe féministe et
militante de la première heure à mal
abdel hadi considère que le bref passage
des frères musulmans au pouvoir en 2012
a aussi provoqué une prise de conscience
politique chez de nombreuses femmes
égyptiennes
c'est toujours cela peut paraître
étonnant aujourd'hui mais la grande
majorité des femmes ne portaient pas le
voile ou siècle dernier en egypte dans
les années 1950 le président nasser se
disaient contre cette pratique
ces rassemblements électoraux il se
moquait du chef des frères musulmans qui
lui demandait d'imposer leur walo femmes
en public même si je n'oublie ebit samus
n a décidé de retirer son hidjab à l'âge
de 26 ans quelques années avant la
révolution de 2011
cette professeur d'université voulait
surtout s'affranchir de l'image de
soumission qu'elle associe au port du
voile a fait et qui nient tous deux leur
sexe manitou
selon cette spécialiste du moyen orient
il est rare qu'une femme soit harcelé ou
agressées parce qu'elles ne portent pas
le voile en egypte surtout pour une
femme de 40 ans comme elle qui vit en
ville
depuis 2014 certains droits des femmes
sont reconnues dans la nouvelle
constitution égyptienne
la violence conjugale est un crime les
mutilations sexuelles également et des
quotas de représentation politique pour
les femmes sont en place si la wind
trong on est tous à tout accepter cette
jeune égyptienne d'adoption affirme
qu'elle n'aime pas la politique et que
ses choix de vie sont tout à fait
personnel il dit d'ailleurs qu'elle
n'exclut pas de porter à nouveau le voit
le jour
si le coeur lui en dit long qu'un animal
il vous retour que nous et même temps on
estime qu'environ 30% des femmes
égyptiennes ne porte pas le voile
actuellement on peut parler de courants
certains mais pas encore d'un phénomène
social majeur
[Musique]